en
1984, ce qui est si habituel avec quatre singles
dans le premier, c'est très stellaire pour une
femme, maintenant, les
femmes se débrouillent plutôt bien en ce
moment, elles se débrouillent très bien dans la musique pop
et en plus, il faut voir les choses de cette
façon, il y en a de plus en plus  d'entre nous on
va mieux
et tu sais qu'ils ne nous mettent plus dans les
rizières donc tu sais
faire mieux ouais on va essayer de trouver des
explications avant tout
tu es un bon artiste bien sûr tu avais du
bon matériel  mais tu as un
look magnifique aussi non est-ce parce que
tu travaillais
dans un magasin ouais magasin j'ai travaillé dans
le magasin de mon amie
et maintenant je la traîne avec moi partout où
elle a conçu sa robe
euh non elle l'a sortie d'un tas de chiffons je
pense
et tu as dit qu'elle euh
elle vend euh des vêtements vintage
et euh euh elle a trouvé cette robe
je l'adore donc tu sais que c'est comme une nouveauté
et surtout tu as le bon
comportement avec les médias tu sais très
bien te
comporter dans  devant les médias maintenant n'est-ce
pas ouais eh bien tu sais que
je connais juste le  les bonnes choses maintenant je ne sais pas
euh j'essaie juste de parler aux gens comme
je parle à n'importe qui une autre chose est que
toi
tu es l'un des premiers artistes de l'ère de la vidéo
tu sais très bien devoir
gérer tes clips vidéo maintenant
bien je '  je m'améliore avec eux et
euh c'est comme cette vidéo j'ai co-dirigé
celle-ci
avec scott calvert et euh
je pense que la vidéo est un endroit formidable
comme un excellent terrain d'entraînement avant
de filmer
ouais et c'est très difficile aussi de trouver un
réalisateur vidéo
qui ne veut pas faire un film
parce que maintenant ils ont fait un film
je préfère juste tu sais si tu vas
faire un film faire un film si tu peux faire une
vidéo tu fais une vidéo
tu sais que ton manager est ton petit ami
tuna  tu ne perds pas de temps je veux dire
non ce n'est plus mon petit ami mais
c'est mon manager et mon meilleur ami
tu ne l'as pas épousé non nous ne l'
avons pas eu nous avons eu une chance nan tu l'as raté
ton deuxième album deux couleurs a eu moins de
succès que
le premier non pourquoi pensez-
vous bien parce que c'était le deuxième
ouais un  d parce que euh
je ne l'ai pas fait parce que ce qui s'est passé est ce que
j'ai fait naturellement est devenu
comme un gadget ouais et je ne voulais pas
faire le gadget
alors j'ai tout pris et en plus de ce que je
faisais tout le monde faisait après un certain temps
ce qui était bien
si  j'ai inspiré les gens à s'habiller tu sais
et à être créatif
tu sais mais euh
je ne savais pas que je devais prendre du recul et
regarder ça et dire
maintenant attends une minute donc je sais qui tu es
mais qui suis-je tu sais comme un  Un de
mes amis je dirais
alors tu es allé à une période étrange avec
tes
vibrations cinématographiques qui n'avaient pas beaucoup de
succès aussi non
eh bien je ne pense pas que j'ai fait du mauvais travail
mais le film d'Adam a eu beaucoup de succès en
france oh ouais
ouais c'était ouais  voyez-vous qu'ils ne l'ont pas fait
et pourquoi êtes-vous allé en Russie à
la fin de
88 parce que j'avais déjà mixé la nuit pour
me souvenir et puis
euh ce n'était pas bien
et je devais le faire
parce que je sentais que je devais obtenir  il sort
en même temps que le film
et dans le film les gens disent
allez tu dois faire de la
promotion et  d tu dois faire ceci tu dois faire cela
et
j'ai commencé à essayer de plaire à tout le
monde
et le seul gars qui n'était pas vraiment
content était moi et à la fin alors
tout le
monde n'était pas content non plus donc
je n'ai pas écouté mon  instincts donc j'ai
tout mis de côté
et l'album n'était pas juste à ce
moment-là
quand ils ont commencé à dire travail avec ce
gars et travail avec ce gars
et ils faisaient en sorte que ces gars fassent le
genre de disques que je détestais
j'ai dit regarde mes amis  allez en
russie je pense que j'aimerais y aller
tu sais parce qu'à ce moment-là la sibérie
aurait été avait l'air bien
imaginez que vous avez une minute nous nous sommes
allés nous rencontrer dans un club comme celui-ci et
vous voulez me parler de votre  dernier
album le troisième un soir pour
te souvenir que me dirais-tu
juste pour me le vendre oh pour
te le vendre je ne sais pas
je dirai juste euh c'est un album dont tu te
souviendras
ouais tu connais l'aveugle  test tu en as entendu
parler ouais d'
accord salut sarah comment tu vas
[Musique]
morphe
[Applaudissements]
non ouais tu as dit qu'elle est magique oui
tu aimes la france tu aimes les cocktails tu
aimes tatty non ouais
qu'est-ce que tu aimes de jack tatty
mr hugo prend des vacances euh
ce sont mes deux favoris oh tu dois
y aller
et aimer louer  eux et recherche parce que
ce n'était pas vraiment disponible mais il est
génial
et cuisiné j'aime orphée
vous savez la nuit vidéo pour vous souvenir
il y a une scène où je marche à travers le
miroir
où cela a été inspiré du moment où la mort
traverse le miroir
pour aller dans leur chambre  et ils
dorment tu sais que
nous avons fait d'une manière différente mais je veux dire je suis passé
de la couleur au noir et blanc et puis j'ai
traversé ouais
mais elle juste tu sais que c'est tout en noir et
blanc ce film est
un film brillant à regarder c'est vraiment
[Musique  ]
génial
[Musique]
oh tu connais le gars c'est miles davis
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu es fier quand il les a adoptés ta
chanson c'est comme si c'était ta vie où as-
tu compris
euh ouais bien sûr  qui ne seraient pas des chansons
de  votre vie
je sais que ça va avec vous tous
oui
oh c'est suzanne c'est les bengals
c'est votre talent je vous dis que je
dois faire je devrais être sur un jeu télévisé
je ne plaisante pas maintenant je suis le gagnant
du jeu mais  tu travailles avec
eux maintenant
ils ont ouvert pour moi lors de ma première tournée ils ont
ouvert pour moi
et ils étaient et je leur ai demandé de chanter
sur euh change your heart ouais
ouais ils sont géniaux c'est tellement agréable
de les voir réussir comme ça  c'est vraiment
[Musique]
c'est
oh je connais cette chanson que je regardais à la télé
oh ouais non je ne m'aventurerais pas contre
maintenant
ouais essaie deux filles
oh mon dieu et j'en parlais juste aussi
non je reconnais cette chanson c'est que je ne  't
[Music]
sais
n'ose pas tu sais qu'ils ont peur de
toi pourquoi
mais qui est-ce qui est-ce wendy et liza
oh tirez c'est vrai princesse filles
mais elles vont bien ici oui elles vont bien
ici ouais
c'est ce que je disais  je regardais
la vidéo en disant bon
sang c'est vraiment bien de les voir tu les
aimes tu les aimes
j'ai toujours pensé  ils étaient talentueux
vraiment talentueux ils n'ont jamais décollé
aux états
ouais ils sont vraiment géniaux et prince
eh bien il a été silencieux il est là tu
l'
as tu dois lui rendre un peu
il est en france
ok on y va
[Musique]
ouais oh mais je viens d'entendre ça
et je pensais que ça ressemblait à princesse
écrit avec prince ouais
ouais c'est ta grande concurrente
elle est ouais
non je ne sais pas parce que je reconnais
prince elle a fait un album avec
quelque chose de vrai
[Musique]
oh c'est madonna
je reconnais le prince ouais c'est très
princier tu veux dire
bien sa voix est très la sienne
aussi mais pas dans celle-ci
elle est ta concurrente elle est ouais
c'est comme des pommes et des oranges tu ne penses pas
que je n'ai pas une chanson comme ça
un homme d'accord
[Musique]
ouais l'un des plus grands guitaristes
du monde
tu plaisantes c'est très astucieux ouais
[Applaudissements]
il a travaillé sur l'album ouais ouais je suis le
dernier album ouais
une nuit pour se souvenir sur laquelle il avait travaillé
ouais  comment
c'était c'était assez incroyable  vable je veux dire
je suis là à regarder comme une
légende aller oh eh bien euh
dans cette chanson je pensais et à l'
arrière de ma tête je vais
ah oh mon dieu j'essayais de garder un
bon sang-froid tu sais
comme  oh euh au fait erica
euh mais il était super une fois que je lui ai expliqué
et il l'a juste joué il l'a fait comme dans
deux trois prises le gars est super ouais
il est juste
mais tout ce qu'il a joué était super tu
sais donc c'est vraiment dur  parce que mais mais
il est très particulier, bien sûr,
tu te connais lui-même mais c'est un super bon
joueur
toi dans les tons sombres je fais ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bleu